[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando ero piccolo soffrivo di dislessia
Questo significa che avevo difficoltà a
leggere non scrivevo bene Ero
perennemente distratto ed ero anche
sopraffatto da
un'estrema
timidezza Quindi potete solo
immaginare quanto possa essere
complicata la vita di un bambino di 7-8
anni che durante la lezione a scuola
cerca di leggere davanti agli altri ma
ha difficoltà quindi sente gli altri
bambini
ridere ma nonostante la mia Diciamo
disastrosa carriera scolastica ho sempre
avuto una caratteristica che mi ha
contraddistinto Ovvero la curiosità
Infatti ho sempre avuto tante passioni
tanti Hobby Uno su tutti è stata
l'informatica Infatti poi è diventato
anche il mio lavoro
e da giovane già studiavo quelli che
erano i linguaggi di programmazione il
funzionamento reale di internet dei
computer quando si vuole però
approcciare una materia del genere è
importante chiaramente saper leggere
saper leggere davanti a uno schermo
davanti a un libro o una rivista al
tempo quindi ho deciso di sforzarmi ho
deciso di spingere su questa mia
passione e quello che notavo è che più
miglioravano le mie competenze tecniche
e più miglioravano anche le mie capacità
di lettura di scrittura e persino di
capacità di parlare in
pubblico al tempo tutto questo mi
sembrava quasi miracoloso Però in realtà
non era un miracolo stavo sperimentando
per la prima volta un un feedback loop
tenete a mente questa cosa perché ci
torneremo tra poco continuando i miei
studi
capivo che c'erano sempre tanti
argomenti che si collegavano gli uni con
gli altri e più studiavo e più aumentava
la complessità e quindi cercavo di
capire come
mai tutte queste informazioni che io
dovevo
elaborare creassero questa complessità
un giorno per caso mi sono imbattuto in
un concetto che ha cambiato per sempre
il mio modo di pensare di vedere il
mondo Questo ora il system thinking o
pensiero sistemico Che cos'è il pensiero
sistemico Avete presente quando durante
i giorni della settimana durante tutto
il giorno Abbiamo sempre tante cose da
fare Siamo sempre molto
impegnati possiamo andare a cercare
magari qualche strategia di produttività
che però a volte è abbastanza
conflittuale no e Iniziamo a pensare ma
è meglio fare prima le cose più
semplici e poi quelle complicate o prima
dedicare le migliori energie per le cose
più complicate e lasciare dopo le cose
più semplici un pensatore sistemico non
pensa né l'una né l'altra in realtà si
chiede Ma perché io ho sempre così tante
cose da fare durante il giorno questo
perché il pensiero sistemico ci invita a
considerare soprattutto i problemi da un
punto di vista diverso più generale
Dall'alto o appunto dal punto di vista
sistemico quando siamo piccoli ci
insegnano che il modo migliore per
risolvere un problema complesso sia
quello di scomporlo in parti più piccole
e cercare di risolverne una alla
volta Questo è un approccio neoniano ha
a che fare molto con il metodo
scientifico e tutta la ricerca però non
è efficace quando dobbiamo risolvere dei
problemi molto complessi
Perché i problemi complessi Generalmente
sono Sì un insieme di sottoproblemi ma
sono collegati guni agli altri infatti
il system thinking studia proprio questo
studia le relazioni tra i problemi Le
interconnessioni poco fa vi ho parlato
de i feedback i feedback loop o i cicli
di loop Se
volete Ecco esistono due tipologie di
cicli di loop i feedback loop positivi e
i feedback loop
negativi mentre Iniziavo a risolvere il
mio problema di
dislessia io stavo sperimentando un
feedback loop positivo cioè un
miglioramento continuo perché più
miglioravano le mie capacità e più
andavo a risolvere il
problema Questo si chiama effetto
retroazione ed è un altro principio del
System thinking lo abbiamo nello
specifico quando il risultato di
un'azione diventa automaticamente
l'input dell'azione
successiva questo lo troviamo per
esempio anche in Finanza con l'interesse
composto Quindi per chi non è
pratico io investo Oggi il mio Capitale
tra un anno questo capitale maturerà
degli interessi e l'anno successivo il
mio capitale non sarà più costituito dal
capitale iniziale ma dal capitale più
gli interessi questo matematicamente
crea una crescita non lineare ma
esponenziale Ed è esattamente l'effetto
che i feedback loop provocano ai
cambiamenti ci sono anche i feedback
loop negativi che fanno la stessa cosa
però in
negativo quello che io sperimentavo e ho
rischiato di sperimentare nel tempo era
un feedback loop negativo dove la mia
difficoltà
incrementava
Adesso vi vorrei invitare a visualizzare
un
iceberg sapete no Gli iceberg sono
composti principalmente da due parti c'è
una parte
emersa fuori dall'acqua visibile è una
parte sommersa che generalmente anche la
diciamo la massa più grande del pezzo di
ghiaccio Ecco immaginate che la parte
Mersa sia in realtà
i problemi che noi vediamo ogni giorno i
problemi con i quali noi ci scontriamo
ogni
giorno per risolverli dobbiamo
necessariamente andare più in profondità
perché in profondità ci sono i modelli
mentali le nostre credenze i nostri bias
cognitivi tutti gli elementi che in
realtà generano il
problema Infatti nel pensiero sistemico
si usa spesso questo esempio
dell'iceberg questo modello dell'iceberg
per descrivere esattamente la filosofia
di
fondo ma il system thinking non è
Chiaramente solo teoria perché i campi
di applicazione sono praticamente
infiniti faccio alcuni esempi lo
possiamo utilizzare in ambito ambientale
per controllare gli impatti che magari
un ecosistema può avere su alcun alcune
Specie per analizzare quelli che possono
essere i problemi più globali dal punto
di vista anche climatico lo possiamo
utilizzare Chiaramente in
economia fatto un esempio prima ma anche
per prevedere e prevenire eventuali
crisi lo possiamo usare nella crescita
personale esattamente come ho fatto io
per instaurare delle nuove abitudini e
per definire degli obiettivi nel medio
lungo periodo
lo possiamo anche utilizzare non so nel
in pratiche come il coaching per avere
ed acquisire una visione di insieme più
completa per aiutare appunto la persona
che stiamo cercando di di cocare
possiamo applicarlo
a alla politica alla grande per definire
le cause di secondo livello e quindi
fare comunque un ragionamento nel lungo
periodo
e chiaramente lo possiamo utilizzare
nelle imprese nelle organizzazioni per
migliorare le performance per sposare
meglio l'innovazione
Adesso vi vorrei dare un piccolo
assaggio di quello che a livello pratico
il pensiero sistemico può fare
all'interno delle vostre vite o nelle
vostre
aziende
Prima di tutto vi serve un problema da
risolvere e questo non credo sia appunto
problema
reperire quello che dovete fare è
prendere Non so per esempio un foglio
una lavagna qualsiasi cosa che si possa
scrivere scrivere quindi al centro un
problema Facciamo un esempio
adesso l'aumento di fatturato di
un'azienda un'azienda che ha difficoltà
di fatturato deve aumentarlo quello che
bisogna fare è quindi scrivere al centro
questo
problema e poi individuare tutti i
fattori diretti o indiretti correlati a
questo problema che riguardano
chiaramente l'azienda può essere
l'assistenza
clienti può essere la politica di
referral o di passaparola riguardanti i
clienti possono essere le performance
dei
venditori può essere l'ufficio Ricerca e
Sviluppo quello che quello che vi pare
il secondo Step è andare ad individuare
quelle che sono le connessioni Fra
Questi fattori non dovete collegarli al
centro dovete collegare ogni singolo
elemento quindi non so l'assistenza
clienti con i referral i referral con le
performance della rete vendita e magari
non so la rete le performance della rete
vendita con Ricerca e
Sviluppo Quando andate a fare questo
andate a creare le prime correlazioni
quindi il vostro sistema sta iniziando a
prendere
corpo Adesso dovete trovare i feedback
loop che possono essere feedback loop di
rinforzo quindi positivi o feedback loop
negativi e quindi andate a creare una
per esempio una procedura tra la
correlazione
tra diciamo assistenza
clienti che migliorata può aumentare la
soddisfazione appunto dei clienti che
possono magari portarci altre persone
che conoscono se noi in mezzo ci
mettiamo una procedura che ci permette
in maniera sistematica di chiedere delle
referenze noi automaticamente avremo più
referenze che possiamo girare all rete
vendita quindi la rete vendita avrà
possibilità di chiudere più contratti
maturare più provvisioni acquisire
magari anche più feedback da parte dei
nuovi clienti e girare questi feedback
non feedback lo feedback inteso come
informazioni girarle magari alla Ricerca
e Sviluppo che può creare quindi
prodotti migliori e migliorare quindi
anche l'esperienza dei clienti quando
avete questo abbiamo creato un
sistema perché questa cosa sarà
replicabile e se voi all'interno di ogni
correlazione inserite questi feedback
loop di rinforzo il sistema migliorerà
nel
tempo il lavoro però non è finito qui
perché la cosa fondamentale da fare è
monitorare questo sistema Perché i
sistemi sono di per sé dinamici e un
sistema dinamico Cambia Cambia o
autonomamente o cambia per vostro volere
perché quando voi andate a modificare un
singolo
fattore quel fattore potrebbe
condizionare anche tutti gli altri
Quindi è importante che voi create una
organizzazione che aopr si dice e
migliora però migliora in maniera non
lineare ma
esponenziale il system thinking quindi
ci invita a fare questo a pensare in
maniera diversa a pensare in maniera più
olistica e ci dà gli strumenti per
creare cose nuove cose diverse risolvere
i problemi in maniera diversa e creare
anche perché no nuove
realtà un aspetto importante quando si
parla di sistemi è come questi sistemi
vengono
interpretati Perché i sistemi abbiamo
detto che cambiano e bisogna
interpretarli nel modo corretto vi
faccio un esempio prendiamo l'esempio
del Lavoro il lavoro di oggi il sistema
lavoro di oggi non è lo stesso di 20
anni fa quindi per comprendere anche
come cambia il mondo non bisogna
applicare le regole di 20 anni fa
Bisogna sforzarsi di guardare come è
cambiato adesso il sistema Perché i
sistemi li possiamo solo sovrascrivere
non possiamo di per sé
modificarli come diceva anche Albert
Einstein Infatti non si può risolvere un
problema con la stessa logica con cui è
stato creato Quindi se volete cambiare
qualcosa nella vostra vita nella vita
degli altri o cambiare anche se volete
il mondo per i più ambiziosi magari c'è
qualcuno create nuove realtà creando
nuovi
sistemi
[Applauso]
Grazie